Let's program one final turn machine.
We're given a binary string,
and we want to accept
if it has an equal number of 0's and
1's, and reject otherwise.
This is going to be an exercise, but
I'll recommend a strategy that leads
to a relatively small number of states.
Starting from the initial configuration,
we'll accept if the current
symbol is blank.
An empty string has a balanced
number of 0s and 1s.
Again, because this is an exercise,
we'll use the character b,
instead of the square cup,
to indicate blank.
And if the current symbol isn't blank
then we can replace it with a blank.
Now, if that old symbol was a 1,
then we move right until
we encounter the next 1.
And we'll change it to an x.
And in fact, if we find a 0,
we go hunting for a 1,
and if we find a 1, then we want
to go hunting for the matching 0.
These have the effect of cancelling
each other out, essentially.
If we don't find a match for whichever
symbol we found here, then we reject.
We found the blank, that means we
reached the end of the string.
If we did find a match, however, then
we need to rewind to the next blank,
that would be the one that
we over rode here, and
change that to X to indicate
that we've crossed it off.
Then we move right past all the xs and
then we're ready to repeat.
Either finding a 0 (1) and
then hunting for its match.
Let's consider the sequence of tape
values for the example input 00101.
First, we blank out the first entry and
then we go looking for
a 1 to match that 0.
Once that is found, we rewind the tape
and mark off this blank here.
And then we step forward until
the next x'd out symbol.
That's a 0, so
we cross it off with a blank, and
then we go look for
a 1 to cancel it out.
And we find one here.
Then, we rewind back to the blank,
cross it out, and
then advance to the next
uncrossed character.
We find this 0, blank it out,
and then we go looking for
a 1, but we don't find one,
so we reject.
This string is imbalanced.
You may use this strategy,
or one of your own,
to construct a turn machine
that decides this language.
Good luck.